.
COLUMBUS IS JUST A PLACEHOLDER
FOR THEIR ANTI-AMERICANISM,
THANK YOU.
AND NOW ANOTHER NORM THE
DEMOCRATS ARE HAPPY TO SHATTER,
DEMOCRAT CANDIDATES AND
INCUMBENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ARE RUNNING SCARED AND AWAY FROM
DEBATES, BECAUSE AS VICTOR SAID,
THEY CAN'T RUN ON THE RECORD.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
RISING CRIME RATES, INFLATION,
RECESSION, CERTAINLY NOT THE
FALLING STOCK MARKET IF YOU LOOK
AT YOUR 401(K) LATELY, NONE OF
THAT.
IN FACT SO DESPERATE TO AVOID
ANY DISCUSSION OF THESE
INCONVENIENT ISSUES THAT SEVERAL
DEMOCRATS ARE EITHER REFUSING TO
DEBATE THAT REPUBLICAN OPPONENTS
OR GREENS FOR ONLY ONE DEBATES
VERY CLOSE TO ELECTION DAY.
IN THE ARIZONA GOVERNOR'S RACE,
LIBERAL KATIE HOBBS APPEARED IN
A SAFE ZONE ON "FACE THE NATION"
TO EXPLAIN WHY SHE WON'T DEBATE
CARY LAKE.
>> I HAVE NO DESIRE TO BE A PART
OF THE SPECTACLE THAT SHE IS
LOOKING TO CREATE.
BECAUSE THAT DOES NOT DO ANY
SERVICE TO THE VOTERS.
>> Laura: OH, REALLY, THAT'S
TOO BAD.
THINK ABOUT THAT, OF COURSE THE
REAL SPECTACLE IS WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO ARIZONA UNDER
JOE BIDEN'S OPEN BORDER.
IT'S A HUGE SURGE IN CRIME AND
HOMELESSNESS, BUT DEFENDING HER
VIEWS ON ANY OF THAT, WELL, THAT
DOES NOT DO A SERVICE TO THE
VOTERS.
WHAT AN INSULT.
ANOTHER REASON TO VOTE STRAIGHT
TICKET REPUBLICAN IN ARIZONA.
AND TO LOOK AT POOR JOHN
FEDERMAN.
I MEAN, THAT MAN SHOULD BE HOME
TRYING TO GET WELL, INSTEAD HE
IS TRYING TO STUMBLE AWAY FROM
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR HIS POSITIONS
ON EVERYTHING FROM ENDING CASH
BAIL TO BANNING OIL AND GAS.
UNCLE FESTER MEN ONLY AGREED TO
ONE DEBATE AND IT IS LATE ON
OCTOBER 25TH.
>> IT IS NORMAL TO HAVE ONE
DEBATE IN OCTOBER, AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WAS TO ALL ALWAYS
THE PLAN, BUT BECAUSE HE HAS
BEEN STRUGGLING IN THE RACE
COMING IN ON COMING HE TRIED TO
TURN THIS INTO AN ISSUE.
>> Laura: STRUGGLING, I JUST
WANTED MORE DEBATES EARLIER AND
NOTING THAT EARLY VOTING STARTED
IN THE STATE IN LATE SEPTEMBER.
IF I WERE A POLITICAL CONSULTANT
ADVISING HOBBS AND FEDERMAN, I
WOULD BE TELLING THEM TO AVOID
DEBATES TOO.
CHANGE THE SUBJECT IMMEDIATELY
FROM THE ECONOMY AND CRIME TO
ABORTION, I DON'T KNOW, TRUMP,
CLIMATE CHANGE, WHATEVER.
LOOK AT, I GOT IT.
THE RECORD IS INDEFENSIBLE.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING MAKES SENSE
AS A SELFISH POLITICAL MATTER TO
AVOID DEBATES, BUT IT IS
INCREDIBLY DISRESPECTFUL TO THE
VOTERS.
SPEAKING OF DISRESPECT, BY THE
WAY, WHAT NEW HAMPSHIRE AND
INCUMBENT SENATOR OR
MAGGIE HASSAN IS DOING TO HER
STATE IS JUST OBSCENE.
SHE IS ONLY HOLDING ABOUT ONE
CAMPAIGN EVENT A WEEK.
I KID YOU NOT.
AND OF COURSE SHE WON'T AGREE TO
DEBATE HER CHALLENGER, NOW IN
NEW ENGLAND, THAT'S WHERE I'M
FROM.
PEOPLE USED TO PRIDE THEMSELVES
ON VIGOROUS DEBATE AND IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE, WHO IN THE NAME
OF ROBERT FROST WOULD THINK THAT
A NEW HAMPSHIRE POLITICIAN WOULD
EVEN CONSIDER HIDING FROM HER
OWN CONSTITUENTS?
HEY MAGGS, THE STATE MOTTO IS
LIVE FREE OR DIE, NOT LET'S FLEE
AND DOCK.
YOU NOTICE THAT BEYOND AVOIDING
DEBATES, LIBERALS LIKE
SENATOR HASSAN, THEY AREN'T EVEN
HOSTING PUBLIC TOWN HALLS
EITHER.
THEY USED TO DO THAT ALL THE
TIME.
SO VOTERS DON'T GET TO ASK FOR
QUESTIONS PRETTY MUCH ABOUT
ANYTHING.
CERTAINLY NOT ABOUT ISSUES THEY
ARE GETTING HAMMERED BY, THE
POLICY SHE VOTED FOR.
FAMILY IS A NEW HAMPSHIRE NOW
ARE BEING FORCED TO GO INTO DEBT
BIG TIME JUST TO AFFORD THE
ESSENTIALS.
HIGH INFLATION COUPLED WITH
HISTORIC INTEREST RATE HIKES
HAVE SOME NEW HAMPSHIRE
RESIDENTS RELYING ON CREDIT
CARDS TO GET BY.
ACCORDING TO THE WALLET HUB, THE
AVERAGE NEW HAMPSHIRE HOUSEHOLD
HAS MORE THAN $8,400 IN
CREDIT CARD DEBT NOW.
NOW THIS IS HEARTBREAKING, IT IS
INFURIATING.
AND LIVED IN THE '80 IS IN
COLLEGE, AND IF YOU WERE A
CANDIDATE WHO WANTED TO COMPETE
AND A LOT OF THEM CAME THROUGH,
YOU HAD TO FACE THE PEOPLE.
YOU HAD TO ANSWER A LOT OF
QUESTIONS, BUT NOW WITH THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT HITTING THE FAN, THEY
ARE GOING TO GIVE MAGGIE HASSAN
A PASS, PEOPLE OF NEW HAMPSHIRE?
HOW IS THAT GRANITE IN YOUR
VEINS?
WHEN AMERICANS ARE SUFFERING, NO
POLITICIAN SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SKATE THREE ELECTION WITHOUT
DEFENDING HIS OR HER RECORD.
NEVER SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
HAPPEN.
AND OF COURSE, TODAY'S MEDIA
PART OF THE PROTECTION RACKET,
HAVEN'T THEY, HOLDING ALL
POLITICIANS ACCOUNTABLE, TO
HOLDING DEMOCRATS COATS.
JOINING ME NOW IS STEPHEN
MILNER, FORMER SENIOR ADVISER TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND FOUNDER OF
AMERICAN FIRST LEGAL AND MIRANDA
DEVINE, NEW YORK COLUMNIST
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND AUTHOR
OF MY FAVORITE "THE LAPTOP
FROM."
STEPHEN, NOW I WANT TO FOCUS ON
NEW HAMPSHIRE, THIS IS THE LIVE
FREE OR DIE STATE, OKAY.
HOW CAN MAGGIE HASSAN AVOID
DEBATING HER OPPONENT AND BE
TAKEN SERIOUSLY BY ANYONE THERE?
>> WELL, SHE SHOULDN'T BE.
ONLY WITH THE INDULGENCE OF THE
LEFT-WING MEDIA IS THAT EVEN
POSSIBLE.
MAGGIE HASSAN HAS VOTED FOR
EVERY SINGLE RADICAL LEFT POLICY
THAT IS RUINING THE STATE OF
NEW HAMPSHIRE FOR THE OPEN
BORDERS AND THE DRUGS THAT ARE
DESTROYING AN ENTIRE GENERATION,
FOR RADICAL GENDER IDEOLOGY, FOR
RAMPANT CRIME, SHE HAS VOTED FOR
ALL OF IT, OR VOTING RECORD IS
INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM THAT OF
BERNIE SANDERS OR CHUCK SCHUMER.
SHE IS A HARD-CORE LEFTIST.
SHE HAS NOTHING IN COMMON WITH
THE PEOPLE OF NEW HAMPSHIRE AND
THAT'S WHY SHE WON'T DEBATE IN
THE MEDIA IS LETTING HER GET
AWAY WITH IT, AND THAT IS A
TRAVESTY.
THE ERA OF OBJECTIVE MEDIA SADLY
IN THIS COUNTRY IS OVER.
>> Laura: MIRANDA, PEOPLE'S
POCKETBOOKS DON'T LIKE,
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT THEY ARE
GETTING POORER, THE STREETS ARE
GETTING LESS SAFE IN AMERICA IS
GETTING WEAKER UNDER DEMOCRAT
RULE.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
THERE'S NO DEBATING THAT.
AND IN NEW YORK GOVERNOR KATHY
HOGLE, SHE HAS NOT BEEN ELECTED
BY THE VOTERS FOR HER POSITION,
SHE HAS ONLY AGREED TO HOLD A
SINGLE DEBATE AND OF COURSE AT
THE END OF OCTOBER, OR EARLY
VOTING HAS ARTIE TAKEN PLACE IN
THE MONTH OF ABSENTEE VOTING I
THINK BY THEN, SO SHE JUST
REFUSES TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
AS WELL.
I THINK THAT IS DEFECTIVE REASON
TO VOTE AGAINST HER.
>> IT REALLY IS, AND I THINK
THAT THE IS VERY WEAK DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES ARE TRYING TO USE THE
JOE BIDEN STRATEGY, AND I GUESS
IT WORKED FOR HIM, SO THEY
FIGURE, WHY NOT FOR THEM.
THEY ARE COWARDS, AND THEY ARE
LETTING DOWN THE VOTERS, THE
VOTERS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING
THE DUE DILIGENCE DURING THE
CAMPAIGN TO DECIDE WHICH
CANDIDATE IS GOING TO DO THE
BEST FOR THEM, WHICH CANDIDATE
HAS THE POLICIES THAT WILL SOLVE
THE PROBLEMS, PARTICULARLY
LOOKING IN NEW YORK, CRIME IS A
MASSIVE ISSUE, AND KATHY HOGLE
REFUSES TO EVEN TELL THE VOTERS
HOW SHE WILL DEAL WITH THE
PROBLEM OF BAIL REFORM THAT IS
LETTING ALL OF THESE CRAZIES OUT
ON THE STREET.
AND SHE WON'T TALK ABOUT THAT
AND SHE KNOWS THAT AS SOON AS
SHE GOES INTO A DEBATE STAGE
AGAINST LEE ZELDIN, SHE --
HE WILL WIPE THE FLOOR WITH HER
AND THAT'S WHY SHE IS RUNNING
AWAY.
BUT SHE WASN'T ELECTED AS YOU
SAY AND SHE IS LIKE A LOT OF
THESE DEMOCRAT CANDIDATES, JOHN
FEDERMAN IS ANOTHER ONE, TRULY A
HOPELESS CANDIDATE, UNFIT,
SPECIAL NEEDS CANDIDATE AND HE
IS ONLY MANAGING TO STAY UPRIGHT
BECAUSE HE IS PROTECTED BY THE
MEDIA.
>> Laura: YES, AND EVEN CNN
WAS FORCED TO REPORT ON HOW
DEMOCRATS NOW VIEW BIDEN'S
PRESENCE AS WE APPROACH THE
MIDTERMS.
>> WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THIS
PRESIDENT'S PLAN IN THE
FINAL FOUR WEEKS?
>> CLEARLY NOT GOING TO THE
RACES THAT MATTER FOR DEMOCRATS,
AND SEEMS LIKE JOHN FEDERMAN
DOES NOT WANT HIM TO APPEAR IN
THE FINAL STRUCTURE OF THE RACE,
AND IS NOT GOING TO GEORGIA.
>> Laura: THIS IS NOT WORKING
OUT WELL FOR HIM ON THE TRAIL.
>> A GIANT ANCHOR, BUT THIS IS
ASTONISHING, LAURA, BECAUSE
EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRAT GO THROUGH
THE LIST, MARK KELLY,
MAGGIE HASSAN, TIM RYAN, THEY
ARE ALL TRYING TO ESTABLISH
DISTANCE BETWEEN THEMSELVES AND
JOE BIDEN.
THEY SPENT THE LAST TWO YEARS AS
HIS MOST LOYAL SURGEON SOLDIERS.
FAITHFUL SERVANTS DOING
EVERYTHING HE WANTED, EVERYTHING
NANCY PELOSI WANTED, EVERYTHING
CHUCK SCHUMER WANTED, WHAT THEY
ARE USING IS WALL STREET MONEY
AND SILICON VALLEY MONEY TO PUT
ADS ON TV THAT ARE LYING TO
VOTERS ABOUT WHO THEY ARE.
EVERYONE OF THEM AND ANOTHER
DEMOCRAT RUN IS AT DOWN THE LINE
JOE BIDEN, NANCY PELOSI,
CHUCK SCHUMER, KAMALA HARRIS
DEMOCRAT WHO HAS ENABLED EVERY
SINGLE POLICY FROM CRIME TO
INFLATION THAT IS WREAKING HAVOC
ON OUR COUNTRY.
AND IF OUR CANDIDATES CAN MAKE
THAT POINT ONCE YOU GET TO THE
DEBATES HAVE CRUSH THEIR
OPPONENTS BY MAKING THOSE POINTS
AS BLAKE DID, AS JAMIE DID.
>> Laura: LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT THAT, STEPHEN, I'M GLAD
YOU MENTION THAT, BECAUSE
TONIGHT JAMIE VANCE EVISCERATED
PHONY POPULIST TIM RYAN, HERE IS
ONE OF THE MANY SUPERB MOMENTS
FROM J.D., CHECK IT OUT.
>> TWO YEARS AGO YOU SUPPORTED
BANNING FRACKING ON PUBLIC LANDS
AND GENERALLY SPEAKING, THAT
CRUSHES THE OHIO ENERGY SECTOR,
AND ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
MANUFACTURERS ARE GOING TO
CHINA, ANOTHER REASON OHIO
MANUFACTURERS GO TO CHINA IS
BECAUSE THE CHINESE UNDERCUT
AMERICAN WAGES, THE ONLY WAY TO
REALLY COMBAT THAT IS TARIFFS.
2018, 2019 AND 2020 YOU OPPOSE
THE TARIFFS THAT STARTED TO
BRING SOME OF THE MANUFACTURING
AND INDUSTRIAL BASE BACK TO
OHIO.
>> Laura: WE HAD THOSE BATMAN
SOUND EFFECTS, THE CUT POWELL,
ZOWWY.
HE JUST FLOORED THEM, AND THAT'S
WHY THEY DON'T WANT TO DEBATE.
>> HE WAS BRILLIANT.
EXACTLY, HE WAS BRILLIANT, YOU
SAW BLAKE MASTERS THE OTHER
NIGHT, BRILLIANT, CARY LAKE,
WOULD BE BRILLIANT, AND
LEE ZELDIN WILL BE BRILLIANT, SO
THE IS DEMOCRATS NOT ONLY DO
THEY HAVE NO POLICIES, NOT ONLY
DO THEY HAVE A TERRIBLE RECORD
AND A PRESIDENT THAT IS A
LAYAWAY, THEY ALSO REALLY DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO
HEAD-TO-HEAD AGAINST THE IS VERY
FORMIDABLE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES.
>> Laura: THEY DON'T HAVE THE
PROTECTION RACKET GOING WITH THE
MEDIA, THEY ARE JUST LEFT ON
STAGE WITH HER POLICY POSITIONS,
AN